des critiques à mon jouerie séraphin
bonjour môsieur stand bonjour aux audits
de martinique 1ère maire de saint pierre
saint pierre qui viennent garder un qui
vient de retrouver son label ville d'art
et d'histoire puisque vous aviez décidé
de vous rendre à paris qui servent à
pour défendre ce label auprès de du
conseil national des villes et pays et
pays d'art et d'histoire
c'est à dire que vous allez vous engager
dans une politique d'animation et de
valorisation du patrimoine bâti naturel
industrielle de votre commune ainsi que
l architecture c'est ça c'est ça le deal
avec ce conseil nouy vous avez bien dit
je enfin disons je n'ai pas et je n'ai
pas décidé d'aller à paris j'étais
convoqué c'était bien une audition dont
il était question
il s'agissait de savoir de ressentir la
volonté du maire qu'il fasse la
démonstration qu'il voulait le
renouvellement de ce label qui était
donc à représenter en 2013
et c'est la nouvelle équipe c'est un
chantier parmi d'autres que nous avons
retrouve que nous avons trouvé est donc
ce label qui était la sienne n'avait pas
donné signe de vie auprès de ce conseil
exactement ce dossier qui devait être
renouvelée en 2012 devait être présenté
en 2012 et la décision prise en 2013 le
nécessaire n'a pas été fait bon il a
fallu défendre parce qu'en fait c'est de
ça qu'il s'agissait de défendre ce qui
s'était passé dix ans entre 2003 et 2013
alors que nous n'étions pas en
responsabilité et présenter aussi notre
volonté de d'avancé qu'elles étaient les
projets que nous avions en tête pour
effectivement des feux valoriser ce
label et en tirer profit pour la
population de saint pierre mais aussi de
la martinique mais avec quels moyens
crise à rafah on se souvient que durant
la campagne pour les élections
municipales et même depuis votre arrivée
vous n'arrêtez pas de clamer de dire
haut et fort que les caisses sont vides
donc justement je voudrais repositionner
les choses
notre programme de ces limites ne limite
pas au label ville d'art et d'histoire à
entretenir le les monuments historiques
et qui elles sont au nombre de 15 et qui
pose un gros problème et c'est bien ce
que le que j'ai tenu à dire au niveau du
conseil
pour la commission qui devant laquelle
j'ai été auditionné je leur ai fait
comprendre que je ne pouvais pas faire
adhérer une population uniquement sur ce
projet est donc une ville telle que
saint pierre avec 4200 habitants et un
budget de 6200 euros 6 million deux cent
mille euros en fonctionnement
je ne pouvais pas moi assumer tout seul
700 ch à poursuivre ce qu'on croit
trouver tout simplement je vais vous
expliquer tout simplement parce que vont
effectivement le manger d'un mêmes
charges que les maires qui sont autour
qui ce qui qui ont à s'occuper de leurs
populations et en plus j'ai un
patrimoine martiniquais j'aime bien leur
répéter je le dis devant monsieur alfred
marie-jeanne jeudi devant tout le monde
je le dis devant le président de cap
nord qui m'écoutent je ne peux pas
d'assumer à moi tout seul il s'agit pas
de cap et du du patrimoine pire hauteur
alors qu'est ce que je fais je laisse
tomber je laisse en ruines le patrimoine
martiniquais ou alors je me bats pour
faire entendre que et c'est ce qui a été
entendu par la commission par la
présidente de la commission qui a bien
leur avait promis vous allez vous leur
avez promis que vous allez tenter de
convaincre les maires avoisinant les
institutions que vous kick de 2 m 2 des
guides en ce compris même le privé et
ils ont bien entendu ils ont dit que
c'était effectivement dans la ligne de
réflexion du du ministère c'est à dire
associer les collectivités les villes
les collectivités mais aussi le privé
pour trouver les moyens d'assumer cette
chose bac est très très belle mission
mais qui vient c'est un élément de plus
par mille parce que depuis deux ans et
demi n'ont pas travaillé que au dossier
du label nous avons fait énormément de
choses nous avons un projet de ville qui
qui vise à améliorer les conditions de
vie des pierrotin qui visent à améliorer
la situation des salariés de la mairie
nous avons fini les chantiers qu'il y
ait qu il y avait à finir ça y est nous
avons fini l'essentiel nous avons nos
projets la zone de mouillage organisée
nous faisons arriver claudio net etc il
ya quand même toujours par exemple un
exemple parmi tant d'autres
il y as à ce trou béant dans la ruhr qui
j'aime le petit commerce et en même
temps ça c'est le quotidien des dd
pirotta est jeune et en même temps mais
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que serait
l'histoire c'est bien pour ça que pour
l'instant en europe roger ne pas en
avoir fait assez pour le patrimoine j'ai
fait ce que je pouvais j'ai bricolé peau
faire tenir à flot ce cet entretien du
patrimoine parce que j'ai le quotidien
du dépotage aurait alors si vous voulez
me meut m'interroger sur ce trou alors
là c'est une histoire absurde parce
qu'en fait ce trou et dans une route
communale sur le plan cadastral
effectivement mais qui a su porter une
circulation territoriale depuis 40 ans
et elle a été conçue pour supporter une
compte une circulation territoriale vers
de prêcheurs vers fort de france en
provenance du mans en rouge est
brutalement en une nuit est redevenu
communal parce que simplement la la la
la la régularisation administrative n'a
pas été fait depuis 40 ans cette rue
route a été entretenu par la région puis
pas même quand je suis arrivé en
responsabilité la 7ème art fait le
revêtement de cette rue mais il se
trouvait et 7 ruraux lous route cette
route oui on relit l'ancien pont le pont
roche et le nouveau pont le nouveau pont
comme cette rue a été reconstruite par
la dde dans les années 70 donc ça
voudrait dire que si on suit le même
raisonnement absurde jusqu'au bout ce
pont qui est au bout de cette rue est
aussi un pont communal et absolue à ça
veut dire que si ces fontes demain matin
on va me dire que c'est à moi de le
reconstruire pour connecter le prêcheur
alors qu'elles auront d'ailleurs le rush
est interdite à la circulation des poids
lourds est tout simplement interdite à
la circulation tout coup parce que c'est
un monument historique prêt à temps ça
veut dire que non mais hier j'ai appris
hier que la septème a voté un budget de
fonds de secours d'urgence
effectivement à hauteur de ce qu'on lui
a demandé c'est à dire 55% l'état s'est
tout de suite mobilisé sur au fonds de
secours d'urgence puisque effectivement
si on se sent fille se fie uniquement à
ce que dit l'administratif c'est une rue
oui mais il n'ya pas que cette rue là
qui pose problème et j'ai d'autres voix
qui n'ont pas été régularisée donc moi
je dit à monsieur alfred marie-jeanne le
président cette haine qui s'est déplacé
à cette occasion à saint-pierre voter si
c'est vraiment une rue communal est ce
que j'ai le droit d'en faire une voie
sur berge une voie piétonne en y mettant
des petites tables le soir pour que les
gens puissent admirer le coucher de
soleil sur le front de mer à
l'embouchure de la roque saunal 060
n'imaginait fait exprès pour pousser le
raisonnement à l'absurde
tout de suite je recevrai bien entendu
une mise en demeure du préfet de
rétablir la circulation
une remarque de se montrer patient le
prix rothen a dû se montrer patients
parce que je n'ai pas 100 mille euros
pour réparer ce trou qui est quand même
une quelque chose d'assez conséquent
puisque ça fait plus de dix mètres
d'escalation en dessous de la chaussée
et la mairie de saint pierre ne pouvait
pas dedans d'urgence débloqués 700 donc
ça va être fait il ya un délai de
travaux de 1 mois j'attends la
notification de la ctm et de l'état pour
lancer une entreprise qui est déjà
choisie qui a contré un contrat de
marché à bons de commande et qui est
prête à travailler
terminons avec ce ce dossier de la route
qui gêne le petit commerce puisque la
situation très difficile revenons
revenons à la ville d'art et d'histoire
oui il n'ya même pas les de
dossiers selon jacky s partir on va
rappeler qu'ici j'acquiesce partir au
fait c'est votre
c'est l'ancienne adjointe en charge de
la culture et du patrimoine qui était
récemment démis de ses fonctions pas les
de dossiers concernant la ville
d'art et d'histoire mah dossier écoutez
les propos les les papiers de cet écrin
de juin qui est venue est devenu le
chroniqueur ou le commentateur de la vie
politique de saint pierre après avoir
été en situation d'agir et il n'a pas
fait grand chose pour ça vous noterez
que dans son papier il ne dit pas non
dans son papier la première chose qu'il
aurait dû faire c'est de commencer par
le défendre le travail qu'il a fait or
il a il
il est allé très loin il n'a pas
seulement pour envoyer à la presse il a
écrit si elle avait un crime et il est
allé loin
il a écrit à l'adac administration dans
laquelle il est employé
il a écrit à son patron alors qu'il est
adjoint en charge du patrimoine et de la
culture à saint pierre dénonçant
l'inaction du maire de saint-pierre dont
il est l'adjoint il a écrit ça à son
patron la démonstration a été faite que
le patron était avec moi à paris en
disant qu' il avait le sentiment
maintenant qu'il avait un véritable
interlocuteur en l'occurrence moi et il
est venu avec moi défendre le dossier de
la ville de saint-pierre à paris
maintenant ils sont rend pas pire disant
que ce qu'il disait c'est à dire que si
on perdait le label ce serait
entièrement de ma faute maintenant on a
le label il dit que cela et c'est grâce
à l'action de deux administratifs dont
je salue le travail c'est-à-dire
l'animatrice du patrimoine qui a fait un
travail remarquable et le directeur de
l'adac monsieur mourinho qui étaient
tous les deux
il sauf que c'est administratif était en
poste avant moi s'il s'agissait
simplement de présenter un dossier
administratif il l'aurait fait avant moi
et le label avoir été renouvelé non on
voulait entendre de mer de saint-pierre
après dix ans de carence du maire
précédent qui avait cassé le service
patrimoine qui avait cessé d'entretenir
les sites qui avaient des plus mauvais
rapports avec le champagne non jeudi la
réalité parce que quand on envoie à
défendre à paris le dossier de mer qui
n'avait rien fait ou quasiment rien ou
très peu en tout cas en tout cas le
bilan était tellement insatisfaisant
qu'il a fallu que j'apporte la preuve
que moi je ne sais que je voulais faire
et c'est ça que la commission entendu et
c'est cela c'est sur quoi la décision a
été prise
merci la résilience et son papier en
plus vise à mettre le bis bis si je peux
dire entre la prison de la ctm et moi
même je trouve que c'est malsain pour la
ville de saint pierre est alors qu'il
n'y a pas de problème actuellement pour
travailler avec même une collectivité
qui n'est pas de ma couleur politique
mais je mets des intérêts de ma ville en
avant merci qui sert à pharand père que
vous êtes le maire de la ville de
saint-pierre merci d'avoir été serein
ténor sans merci bonne journée
[Musique]